[Música]
você já se perguntaram quem é
responsável pela sujeira
já imaginaram se o lixeiro ficar sem
passar durante um mês
o quanto de lixo que a gente vai
acumular dentro de casa já fizeram esse
exercício
a gente aprende a limpar a casa da gente
a gente aprende a deixar tudo limpinho
atirar o lixo no dia que o lixeiro passa
a gente também aprende a não jogar lixo
no chão mas na verdade fazer isso não é
nada mais do que o mínimo que a gente
tem que fazer com relação ao nosso lixo
para viver num lugar limpo e até a casa
da gente limpa dentro dela limpinho é
uma ilusão se a gente parar pra pensar
que a nossa casa tá dentro de um planeta
que a gente está chorando
então no fundo no fundo a gente está num
meio da sujeira e se for difícil
imaginar o planeta a gente pode pensar
que daqui a um tempo a gente vai estar
consumindo comida contaminada porque foi
com o foi implantado em solo contaminado
e regada com água contaminada
tudo isso dentro da nossa casa limpa e
até pouco tempo eu também não tinha me
feito essa pergunta de verdade e esse
aqui é um dos motivos pelos quais eu
tenho me tornando mais responsável pelo
meu lixo
essa é a minha composteira ela é uma
composteira de segunda mão ela já foi
modificada ela tem furos que não deveria
ter na original mas mesmo assim ela
funciona super bem aí dentro tem minhoca
tem resíduo da minha cozinha tudo que ia
ser jogado no lixo da cozinha
praticamente vai lá pra dentro e lá
dentro as minhocas resolvem isso de uma
forma muito rápida e e transformam e
chile
chu em terra basicamente essa
composteira é muito importante pra mim
hoje porque ela me trouxe uma satisfação
que eu não estava tendo na minha
profissão por exemplo eu estava um pouco
frustrada eu sou bióloga me formei em
2010 e desde então eu tenho me dedicado
à pesquisa
dentre algumas outras coisas e resumindo
o foco da minha pesquisa é conservação
ambiental
só que eu estava começando a me
incomodar muito porque eu trabalho com
conservação ambiental eu escrevo
trabalhos sobre isso eu faço essa
pesquisa mas para ela se tornar prática
para alguém que toma uma decisão em
relação ao meio ambiente olhar para a
minha pesquisa e colocar isso em prática
pode ser um processo muito lento e
também pode ser que nem aconteça e uma
das coisas que me incomoda muito que não
é parte da minha pesquisa é o lixo que a
gente produz porque já não cabe mais
se a gente for consciente mesmo a gente
vai ver que o lixo que a gente está
produzindo já não cabe mais no planeta
ea gente tem causado danos para lugares
e para seres vivos que a gente nem
imagina a gente está fazendo isso aqui
achando que não está afetando tudo isso
epa ea gente está se afetando e todo
esse lixo que está fazendo todo esse
estrago ele começa dentro da casa da
gente
segundo uma pesquisa realizada em
campinas
este ano 13 por cento do nosso lixo é
considerado rejeito 37% é considerado
resíduo orgânico e 50% resíduo
reciclável que isso significa de verdade
isso significa que só 13% disso tudo é
lixo de verdade o resto
cinzas e lixo mas quando a gente joga
fora tudo junto a gente transforma tudo
a gente transforma 100% em rejeito a
gente tem o poder de reduzir o nosso
lixo e 87% se a gente usar essa pesquisa
como base
então por que a gente não faz porque a
gente não faz isso pra cuidar do nosso
reciclável a gente vai precisar de
maquinários
a gente vai precisar de pessoal a gente
vai precisar de transporte e nós é cada
um de nós só tem a responsabilidade de
separar esse lixo e colocar pra fora no
dia certo a gente não participa desse
processo todo e como ele exige grandes
investimentos cada um de nós não
consegue reciclar o plástico que usa em
casa
ao contrário disso na compostagem
a gente pode fazer sozinho cada um de
nós pode construir uma composteira em
casa ela pode ser de caixa como é a
minha ela pode ser de baldes e
reutilizados
ela pode ser no chão pra quem tem espaço
pra quem tem quintal
não custa nada e se você tiver dinheiro
você pode comprar uma pronta existem
várias pra comprar pronto
todas as informações para fazer a
compostagem dá certo a gente encontra na
internet
a gente pode achar guias manuais vídeos
está tudo disponível na palma da mão no
celular
então de novo porque é que a gente não
faz
e aí pensando nisso eu imaginei que o
primeiro motivo seria que muita gente
não tem essa informação muita gente não
sabe que dá pra fazer que é fácil que
não precisa de investimento e que pode
ter dentro do apartamento que pode ter
dentro da casa que não precisa ficar do
lado de fora e aí pensei nisso
mas eu percebi que esse não era o meu
caso eu tinha essa informação
essa é a composteira dos meus pais eu
vejo a compostagem ser feita na casa dos
meus pais desde criança e eu saí de lá
há 12 anos e eu só comecei a fazer
compostagem no ano passado
eu acho que a gente tem uma resistência
mesmo em fazer uma coisa diferente né
essa composteira composteira dos meus
pais ela não era minha composteira é
diferente e mudar um hábito é muito
difícil às vezes
primeiro ganhei a composteira de uma
amiga a minha composteira de segunda mão
e ela já tinha sido usada de outras
formas não só para conquistar e ela
ficou parada no quintal durante um tempo
vazia
mesmo sabendo que era ótimo
mesmo sabendo que não era difícil mesmo
sabendo que não tinha motivo nenhum para
não fazer de novo eu demorei pra fazer e
aí depois de um tempo com ela lá parada
eu e meu companheiro resolvemos começar
a compostagem e hoje tudo que sai da
nossa cozinha que é compostável vai pra
lá
é muito gratificante ver o processo de
transformação porque como eu falei
diferente da compostada reciclagem na
compostagem a gente enxerga a gente vê
que o mês passado tinha casca e agora
tem terra é muito fácil enxergar isso a
gente participa de todo o processo de
transformação e hoje em dia ficou a
gente fica muito feliz em ver o nosso
lixo diminuir hoje sai um dom uma
sacolinha de lixo da nossa cozinha por
semana e é um lixo que nem cheiro ruim
então se o cheiro não passar durante um
mês
não tem o menor problema porque dá pra
deixar guardado lá em casa não vai fazer
um grande volume de lixo nem vai cheirar
muito ruim e de novo essa satisfação é
muito importante pra mim porque a minha
pesquisa é uma tentativa de promover a
conservação ambiental mas pode nunca ser
prática e eu fazendo compostagem dentro
da minha casa sou eu na prática
promovendo a conservação ambiental e ter
tomado essa atitude tão simples de
começar essa composteira é muito
reconfortante é muito reconfortante pra
mim como bióloga mas também como uma
pessoa comum que percebe a importância
de cada um de nós para a mudança que é
necessária para a gente ter mais
respeito mais respeito com a terra mais
respeito com os outros seres que habitam
a terra junto com a gente mas ok muita
gente pode não se importar
não me importo com os lugares que a
gente está sujando não me importo com os
animais que a gente está prejudicando e
nem com os outros seres humanos que a
gente está prejudicando e mesmo se a
gente pensar da maneira mais egoísta
a gente ainda vai ter motivo para ser
mais responsável pela nossa própria
sujeira eo motivo somos nós mesmos
depois que a gente começa a fazer as
mudanças
é um caminho sem volta então se a gente
já separou reciclável e já composta
novos bons hábitos vão vir e vai ser
muito mais fácil porque a gente vai
querer usar coletor menstrual a gente
vai querer usar fralda de pano nos bebês
a gente não vai querer aceitar o
canudinho a gente vai querer aproveitar
a água da chuva a gente vai querer
aproveitar a água da máquina de lavar e
mais um monte de coisa porque a gente
sabe que cada coisa tem o seu lugar ea
gente também sabe as conseqüências da
nossa bagunça
só que essa mudança tem que começar
agora não dá mais tempo de esperar
segundo o painel o relatório do painel
intergovernamental sobre
essas climáticas que foi divulgado em
outubro deste ano
se a gente não começar a mudar agora
daqui há 22 anos em 2040 22 anos
todo mundo vai estar assistindo com uma
intensidade muito maior
as consequências da nossa
irresponsabilidade da nossa falta de
empatia pelo planeta pelos outros
é muito pouco tempo mas ainda dá tempo e
só depende da gente tomar uma atitude
simples e quando há mudança dentro da
gente estiver consolidada a gente vai
exigir política pública a gente vai
fiscalizar a gente vai até falar no
texas mesmo morrendo de vergonha porque
a gente acha que esse é um assunto que
deve ser falado e que todas as pessoas
precisam ouvir porque depende só delas e
é isso que tem acontecido comigo e que
eu espero que aconteça com vocês
obrigada
[Aplausos]